where does America stand America
is a
at a Crossroads because both sides seem
to not like the country that much
anymore the left doesn't like America
because of what America has been
America's so evil it's got the original
sin and so of that's the slavery and so
it's always bigoted and evil and the
right is increasingly disenchanted with
America because America is standing for
what America is standing against the
rule of law standing against
self-government America standing against
Christianity America standing against
even the distinction between men and
women and America's values that we're
exporting around the world are what it's
wokeness and the rainbow flag
you just have the Pentagon confirm that
lgbtism is a key American value that we
are protecting overseas
that's what we're that's what we're
exporting no longer truth justice in the
American way we're just trying to raise
a pride flag in Kandahar okay count me
out of intervention then I guess Sunny
Hosten made this point on The View Sunny
host and one of the cackling hens who
who said America we're no better than
any other country around the world when
I listened to Christopher Ray the Pres
the the head of the FBI he said white
supremacy is the biggest domestic threat
to this country and so as a woman of
color with a six foot two black kid in
college and a five foot seven five foot
eight black kid in high school I don't
see that part of American exceptionalism
I'm sorry I think this country has a lot
of problems that could be solved yes
maybe they're putting Muslims in jail in
Afghanistan I think you mentioned and
China they're putting a lot of black
more black people in jail
there it is so so yeah sure China is
engaged in a process of mass
sterilization they've long been engaged
in a process of Mass Slaughter through
abortion and yeah they're they're
engaged in ethnic cleansing and they're
sending a particular religious and
ethnic group to a prison camp
but
America arrests Black Street criminals
so it's like kind of it's kind of the
same thing right I don't think it's the
same thing
you'll see a lot of knee-jerk right-wing
reactions to this clip from The View
they'll say you're anti-American how
dare you make a comparison between
America and any other country on earth I
don't think that's
necessarily Beyond The Pale I'm not
opposed in principle to making these
kinds of comparisons I made one of these
comparisons yesterday
I said that the United States we allege
that we're going to ban Tick-Tock that's
why the the unit party in Washington DC
is in favor of this bill to restrict act
to ban Tick Tock except the bill doesn't
ban Tick Tock what it does is it gives
the government and unaccountable
bureaucrats more control over what
people get to say on the internet
that's my problem with it
we point out that China has a social
credit score well America in many ways
has a social credit score if you say
things that are heterodox or if you say
things that contradict the the
prevailing line of the regime or if you
say things that are genuinely nasty
you can be completely ostracized from
society put on a no-fly list de-banked
kicked off of every social platform
you're just done
is that so different from a social
credit score China has mass surveillance
oh you want to talk to Americans about
mass mass surveillance
uh yeah I think
I think uh we we know a thing or two
about surveillance of our own citizens
in this country well in China they
arrest political dissidents oh uh yeah
tell me how are the grannies doing in
solitary confinement because they
decided to take a picture in the capital
rotunda on January 6th the worst day
ever in the history of the world
yeah no I look these comparisons are
fine
to make it's a way of improving our own
country but the comparison that Sunny
Hosten is making here is in apt
what Sunny Hosten is doing is simply
encouraging criminality
saying yeah the Chinese are persecuting
the uyghurs the way the American
government persecutes black men the
difference is the uyghurs aren't
committing crimes
they're not having the law which applies
to everybody just enforced against them
sometimes frankly not even all of the
time which is what we're talking about
here when you say well black men are
being arrested at disproportionately
high rates
not really they're they're just
committing crimes at disproportionately
high rates would that we're not so
it'd be great let's try to reform
something that's fine by me but the libs
don't want to reform anything in fact
the lips want to encourage criminality
and go easy around the criminals which
means they won't be rehabilitated they
won't be reformed these problems are
going to persist they're going to plague
in particular
these communities
but if you go soft on it you're just
going soft on crime which is of course
what the libs want to do
the libs encourage this criminality
because it allows them to clamp down and
claim more power and it allows them to
use
these groups of people
as a cudgel to intimidate
ordinary innocent
civilians I'm not just talking about
Street criminals in the inner cities I'm
talking about people at universities
there's a Wayne State University
professor
Stephen shaviro who has just come out
and encouraged
leftists to murder
me to murder me to murder Matt Walsh to
murderer Ben to where all of us here at
the daily wire and to murder Tennessee
legislators and to to but specifically
to murder conservatives who come to
college campuses and speak out in
defense of reality against the absurdity
of transgender ideology here's what he
said he said here's what I think about
free speech on campus although I do not
Advocate violating federal and state
criminal codes I think it is far more
admirable to kill a racist homophobic or
here's the key transphobic
speaker than it is to shout them down
what is transphobic mean it means
pro-reality
transphobic the irrational fear of
of affirming Disturbed people in their
misperception of reality
of encouraging people who according to
at least one major study
are
the most likely to support violent
radicalization to encourage them to kill
us that's what the professor has done
the professor has
been suspended he obviously should have
been fired on the spot
and perhaps should be prosecuted I'm not
sure that this statement Rises quite to
the level of a direct threat
but we are all giving speeches now we'll
see I've got a lot of speeches lined up
I have no intention of shutting them
down there I think that we'll we'll see
how how much Vengeance the the libs are
trying to wreak but as of now all of
these speeches are on
and we're going to continue
we're going to continue to speak the
truth and I don't care if some Wayne
State University Professor is
threatening to or encouraging his
students to kill us all
we will not be made in lies this is we
will not be made to live in Wise this is
this is the
greatest political revolution in the
history of the world it's the political
revolution of Christianity
until the Incarnation and the
crucifixion and the resurrection
until that time political rulers had a
trump card which is if you don't do what
we say even if what we say is harmful
even if we if what we say is false if
you don't live according to the lies
that we insist you live under we will
kill you and that was that and that's
the end of life and then you're over and
what the pivot of History the
Incarnation inaugurates is a period in
which political rulers lost that trump
card
because no matter how tyrannical and
Powerful a political ruler is they can't
they can't take away your soul and they
can't take away your eternal life
they can they can make you scream but
they can't make you talk
they can't make you repeat their lies
they can make you scream they can harm
your body but they can't take away
your life ultimately they can't take
away your life we've got a lot more
coming up in the member block
got a lot on a i producer Jacob has
taken over the show today we'll see how
he does head on over to the Knowles
stradamus member room segmentum
dailywire.com Knowles promo code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you